One of the things that I've thought
a bit of a tangent,
but I'll move back to
the mortal afterwards.
See,
I really liked the psycho analyst and
I liked the idea that you have a psyche
that's inside of you and that that is
structured in partly consciously and in
part conch unconsciously.
There's something about that that's really
cool and I've learned a lot from the
psychoanalyst,
but you know,
there is a funny consequence of thinking
the way they think and you do think the
way they think,
even if you don't know it.
Like we tend to think that a
lot of us is inside our head.
You know,
that's the psyche model basically.
But the more I've practiced
as a clinical psychologist,
the last,
I've actually been
convinced that that's true.
So I could say,
well,
let's say I want to know
about your personality.
We think,
well,
I want to know you.
I want to know about your subjectivity.
I didn't want to know
what's inside of you.
But that isn't actually what you do.
Want to know if,
if,
if you're doing clinical work,
say with someone you want to know,
did they have any friends?
That's really important because if you're
miserable and anxious and badly placed
in life and misbehaving,
one of the reasons that all of that
can occur is because you don't have any
friends.
You don't know anyone,
and that's not something
that's inside you.
It's,
it's you localized in a broader sphere.
And then you might say,
well,
do you have a job and well,
let's talk about the job.
Do you actually make
enough money with your job?
Is it satisfying for you in any way?
Are you bullied all the time?
When you're at work?
Does it provoke anxiety?
Is it a career that allows
you to go somewhere?
Are you overwork?
Well,
but let's start with
just the first question.
Do you have a job?
Well,
if the answer to that is no,
you have a serious problem
and that would enough.
Might be too depressed you and make you
anxious and hopeless and nihilistic and
all of those things.
And you could say,
well,
you're not reacting very
well to not having a job,
but that's kind of a foolish objection.
Even though some of it might be true.
One problem is,
is that you're not reacting
very well to not having a job.
But another problem is that you don't
have a job and that actually constitutes a
problem,
right?
You don't get to eat.
You don't have a place to live.
So those aren't psychological problems.
Precisely,
even though a psychological
problem could make it worse.
Well,
are you as educated as you should be?
That's another question.
How do you handle drugs and alcohol?
Are they taking you down a bad pathway?
You know?
Um,
what about intimate
relationships be have one,
you have a plan for one or they,
is that a never ending series of
catastrophes or something that you avoid
completely.
That's a big problem.
And maybe people don't,
aren't attracted to you
for one reason or another.
And you could think about that
as a psychological problem,
but it's an interpersonal problem.
And the degree to which that's
a psychological problem is,
is certainly an unspecified.
When you first begin talk to somebody,
what about your family?
Do you have a family?
Cause it's hard to be in
the world all by yourself.
That's for sure.
It makes things a lot more stressful.
Even though having a family can
also be extraordinarily stressful.
You don't,
do you have plans to have children?
How are you doing with your parents?
Do you get along with your siblings?
You know,
all of that.
All of that to me is more fundamental.
And it's outside of you.
Those are elements of your experience
more broadly conceptualized more than they
are objects of your psychology
or of your internal experience.
You know,
it's sort of like
while a person is,
uh,
is it is a creature that exists
at multiple levels of analysis,
right?
Something might go wrong
with you at a cellular level,
so maybe you're born with
a genetic abnormality,
so something's wrong with you molecularly,
or you have something
wrong with a major Oregon.
Or maybe there's something
wrong with you psychologically.
Or maybe you're in a pathological family
or maybe you're stuck in a pathological
social system and and figuring out what's
why you're suffering means going up
and down those different levels.
Trying to specify the appropriate level
for analysis and also the appropriate
level for intervention.
And for me as a,
as I've said,
even though I'm a great admirer of the
psychoanalysts and I do things like dream
analysis,
which I really find you an incredibly
useful and enlightening the first,
the fundamental level of analysis is,
well,
what's your experience structured like?
Exactly.
And that isn't localized in you.
Now the behaviorists do that too because
what's one of the things I really liked
about the behavioral
approach to psychotherapy,
it's very,
very concrete and practical.
It's like they'll say,
well,
there's certain things that you need to
have in order to live properly and maybe
you don't have the skills or
the wherewithal wherewithal
to accumulate them and
we'll break them down into tiny
little pieces and you'll practice.
So,
for example,
with someone who doesn't have any friends,
then you do a micro analysis of their
social skills saying maybe an analysis of
the kinds of anxiety that are stopping
them from going out and meeting people
and then you address those
things practically one by
one you tried to get the
person to have some friends.
He tried to figure out how they can
establish an intimate relationship.
You see if you can help
them sort out their family,
you do what you can
about their employment.
And a lot of that's only tangentially
related to really in some sense to the
structure of their psyche.
But one of the things you'll see if you
work as a clinician or as a counselor is
that most of the time people come and
see you because they have problems,
not because they have
psychological problems.
And those things are not
that easy to distinguish.
You know,
it's sort of the psychoanalytic idea,
sort of like,
well if you just start your act together,
everything would work out for you.
It's like,
yeah,
there's some truth in that,
but,
but you know,
if you're 55 years old and
you've just been laid off work
and maybe through no fault of your own,
it isn't obvious how much
getting your act together,
it's going to help you find another job
because the actual problem that you're
facing me have relatively
little to do with you.
And that would especially be the case if
you're maybe on the bottom half of the
intelligence distribution for example.
And so it isn't as easy for you just
to go out and pick up new skills at the
drop of a hat,
you know?
And that gets harder as you get older
because your Iq actually declines quite
substantially as you get older.
The working or the the fluid
intelligence part anyways,
exercise can keep that at bay,
by the way.
It's the best way to keep that at bay.
So anyways,
you can think from the phenomenological
viewpoint of your experience as a whole
instead of you being a
subject in an objective world.
And so here's another way of,
here's something that's quite useful.
You'll,
Elon talked about this because he
was moving towards a phenomenological
perspective later in his life.
The last book he wrote was
called mysterium connectionists
and he talked about
three conjunctions that needed to take
place in order for someone to be well
constituted psychologically.
And you know how Piaget talked about
learning that you could not only follow
rules but that you could make rules for
new games is sort of the highest level
of moral development.
I would say young extended the Piagetian
moral continuum up past what Piaget had
envisioned.
Now he didn't,
he didn't do that cause he wasn't
trying to extend Piaget's model.
But,
but you can think about it the same
way and it's not easy to come up with a
moral motive being say that transcends
the ability to make rules for new games.
That's damn smart man.
That's,
that's,
that's a major home run by
Piaget as far as I'm concerned.
But Young said something like this said,
look,
when you're going through the
process of psychological integration,
here's a way of conceptualizing it.
And he thought about this as
symbolically as male female pairings.
Because as I've tried
to point out the most,
one of the most fundamental character
categories that are mythological
imagination uses to structure the
world is the category of masculine and
feminine.
And in moves that around,
you know,
it's,
it's a fundamental metaphor.
So you can move that around anywhere.
And so young thought,
well one of the things that you're trying
to do is to get your thoughts and your
emotions integrated.
And so,
you know,
the Classic Enlightenment Viewpoint,
roughly speaking,
is something like passion
is the enemy of reason,
right?
And so to the degree that your rational,
it's sort of a Friday of viewpoint.
It's cause he got your emotions under
control and there's some truth in that,
but not enough truth.
I like the Piagetian idea better,
which is that,
no,
that isn't what happens.
What happens if,
if you're playing the proper game
is that you integrate your emotions
underneath.
You're thinking something like that.
So they're all working
in the same direction,
you know?
So for example,
you can make your anxiety
work against you or for you.
And one of the ways I did it,
I made a program called the
future authoring program
that I think helps people
do that because one of the things you
see when you're talking to people and
they're trying to solve problems is
that they're afraid to face the problem.
And so then their anxiety
is working against them.
And you can think about it as a,
as antagonistic to rationality,
but then I could say,
well,
why don't you think for a while about
what your life would be like if you didn't
face this problem?
Because if you think that through,
if you have a problem and you really
think through what the consequences are
going to be in three to
five years of not facing it,
then you're going to get
more afraid of not facing it,
then facing it.
And that's great because then your anxiety
instead of standing in front of you,
instead of you having a dragon that's
guarding the path in front of you,
where you have one chasing
you down the path from behind,
that's a lot more useful.
And so,
you know,
that's just a minimal example of the
utility of getting your emotions and your,
and your thoughts aligned the same way.
The same thing happens with aggression.
You know,
one of the most common reasons that people
come and seek psychotherapy really is
because they're too agreeable.
But what that means is
they're not assertive enough.
They have an integrated their
capacity for aggression.
And so other people can
push them around and,
and they're very conflict avoidant.
And,
and so the consequences of that across
time is that you don't stand up for
yourself well enough and you get taken
advantage of and that spirals badly
downward.
And so partly what you do when you're
doing assertiveness training with people
is you find out what they're angry about.
And there are usually Angley angry if
they're not assertive enough because other
people are taking advantage of them.
Or You could say because they're not
putting their own necessities forward with
enough force.
It's hard to distinguish
between those two things.
But anyways,
you try,
you get them to talk about what they're
angry about that often makes them cry
often many times.
And then you get them to kind of envision
what they would want to have in stead,
which they're often afraid to do because
people are afraid to think about what
they want because that makes it more
clear when they're not getting it.
And that's painful,
right?
Or maybe they're afraid of hoping
so they won't specify a clear aim.
But anyways,
you get them to think
about what they might want.
Instead you get them to think about the
costs of not pursuing that and then you
help them develop strategies
for integrating their
aggression and with their
thinking so that they can come up with
a plan to approach the world in a more
confident way.
So for example,
someone might come to me and say,
I'm being bullied badly at work.
And so then I'll say,
well,
what are your options?
You have to put up with it.
Well we'll,
we'll figure that out.
Cause maybe you do,
maybe you don't have options,
but here's how to find out.
Get your damn CV together
so it's pristine,
right?
It's,
it's ready to go get over your fear of
a new interview because it people are
generally afraid of that.
Get over your,
of applying for a new job.
Start thinking about what it would
mean to have a different job.
Start thinking about what it would mean
to have a better job even because maybe
your fear is just making you stuck here.
But I can tell you one thing,
if someone's picking on you at
work and you don't have options,
you lose.
So you get the person to
start building a strategy.
It's like,
okay,
if you're going to tell
this person to stop,
you have to know how to make them stop
and one and the one thing you need for
sure is an option.
And if you can't,
if you don't have an option,
then maybe we start thinking about the
fact that you need some more training or
something like that because you cannot
negotiate if you don't have any power.
So because while,
especially if you're dealing with someone
who's really out to get you or really
disagreeable,
if you don't have a leg to stand on and
they'll just push you over and maybe
they'll jump on youtube because that's
what they're like and they enjoy it
anyways.
So it's no joke.
So you'll put your options behind
you and then you start to think about
strategies.
So I tell people,
look,
if you're being harassed at work,
you document it every time it
happens and you write it out.
So you've got like 20 stories
about it and it's fully documented.
And then you go confront
the person at some point,
but with at least three pieces of evidence
and you have some sense of what you
tell them about what will
happen if they don't stop.
So you have to figure out,
well,
if they don't stop,
what are you gonna do about it?
Leave.
Not if you can't leave.
So you,
you have to be able to,
what is it wield a big
stick and speak softly,
but you see that way.
It's,
that's how you take your aggression,
which is an absolutely necessary part
of your psyche and manifest it up into a
sophisticated means of
dealing with the world.
You don't just suppress it.
You say,
well I should be able to put up with
it or I wish I wasn't so angry or
something.
It's like forget that.
That's all that'll happen is your blood
pressure will stay high and you'll die
of a heart attack.
Because anger for example,
is a very toxic emotion and it
does cause heart damage over time.
It's the only emotion that we really
know that's been linked to things like
cardiovascular risk and anger is,
is toxic because it's
like you're driving a car,
you've,
you're stepping on the gas and pushing
on the brake at the same time because
anger tells you to run away and to attack
at the same time cause you don't know
what's going to happen.
And so it,
it really amps up the
physiological demand on your body.
And so if you,
including your heart and your musculature.
So if you stay like
that for like 10 years,
you know you're going to age
20 years and that's a bad plan.
So,
so,
you know,
you take your underground emotions and
you integrate them into a sophisticated
reality.